jouant face au blind test spécial bouffe
pour sébastien hongre éteint la lumière
en même temps aux joutes des ciels
bouffe messieurs spécial bouphavanh
manger avant de faire le régime non non
je fais pas de régime on y va il faut
trouver le nom il faut trouver le nom
soit du chanteur on peut jouer tout le
monde joue au secteur soit soit du
chanteur sun la chanson l'accord
répondait quoi à loisy béziers première
les cornichons brevets attention
attention didier deuxième morceau bamboo
dj laisse courir un peu vivier
william cher williams après troisième
chanson attention et moi du couscous et
ribab adam
oui jouer du siala mais où est joué
mais jamais je n'ai joué que jamais sur
l'histoire était charles trenet vous un
honneur les chansons alors on continue
didier prochaine chanson je suis
concentré vous souffle sébastien parce
qu'il allie d'abord je viens créatif
allardon tout de suite à fait d'accord
bon on continue sa cellule et à claire
il manque au salon julien tribunaux
ceaucescu incurie c'est toujours lui qui
non merci
oui ballet lemercier goûter mes frites
ouais là tu sais c'est bien maintenant
une chanson pour ne pas nier michel
polac didier suggère la confiture selon
m
depuis que les listes lui parle de
livres trouver tous les sites dans la
constitution les plages alors les listes
j'y arriverai un peu plus sur le fond la
prochaine fois je dirais la première
phrase d'un livret oxibis à la civic
l'insipide pardon un conflit dur sinon
ouais non maintenant et lui les trous
matin était le plus fort que j'ai vu
jusqu'à maintenant on continue ça c'est
une chanson pour toi patrick on y va on
continue didier teinture lobala bons
joueurs de blind test fabrice maintien
j'adore ça s'écoute et j'ai fait que ça
écouter les chansons d'abba lycée à
s'affirmer émulation mais en même temps
alors on soutient t elle
génial a vraiment j'ai jamais vu ça
latin des annonces ici rien il ya une
main considération c'est déjà beaucoup
j'étais déjà là on continue via déjà oui
on continue
bravo bravo peut l'applaudir
bon je n'ai pas la dernière la halle et
didier mais c'est comme à la télé on
peut rallumer la lumière s'il vous plaît